good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone had a great
week so far we had a great week we broke
bread
we
topped the charts we're just still
charming
queens mogul energy everywhere
last night was the second episode of
breaking bread so much fun if you joined
thank you for joining we it was a
journey you know it was a journey we're
there you know yes it was exciting we
also yesterday was like the busiest day
ever because you know meetings meetings
meetings mogul mogul mogul we also
vlogged our entire day because a lot of
people are like you guys work for an
hour a day actually [ __ ] no we don't
and we've vlogged it to prove it okay we
did a whole day in the life what it's
like to be a mogul um it's up on our
patreon now we had meetings meetings
meetings we spent time with harry you do
get like a peek at harry's like stomach
so it's kind of sickening it is pretty
sickening it was a harry luscious day
but also a working day
very busy but good and now we're signing
into the end of the week and i did cheat
the week it's a three-day week for me
but you know a week is a week no matter
how you slice it and we're getting
through i actually don't think i agree
with that a week is not a week no matter
what you say like even though monday and
tuesday i wasn't here in the studio like
i was still suffering through week
things no a week is a week no matter how
you slice it no i said what i said i'm
not gonna agree with you a week is not a
week a monday a five day work week is
not the same as like when you get you
know the monday off you know no of
course but still it's the week and you
made it to the next one no it doesn't
count like in in the life cycle of like
hard weeks it doesn't count i had a hard
week yeah
um
last night was the real housewives of
beverly hills did you watch nope because
my youtube tv subscription paused and it
didn't record my shows until i went to
watch it and they were like update
payment which i eventually did but i
already missed the recording
okay that's so funny because i literally
got a bill no
i texted you guys and i was like is
anyone else having a spectrum outage and
you guys are like no
turns out i haven't paid my bill in
literally three months i'm on autopay
like who the [ __ ] doesn't use autopay
and they get just
they turned it off so i got a bill
they're like you literally owe us three
months of cable
wi-fi and home phone
and i was literally gonna get my cable
shut off my wi-fi was being spotted
because they were turning it off oh my
god i was like oh my god am i okay like
oh my god i have to film a live show you
know it's just like
who's the [ __ ] turned off my autopay
i know who it was
it was olivia
i'm telling you olivia is always up in
my spectrum account one time olivia did
the most annoying thing i'm a generous
sister she needed like a login for
some you know app to use my if you use
your cable so i give it to her in
shapiro i'm so generous
literally i get a call from olivia and
she's like you owe me like 500 i'm like
excuse me she's like yeah like when i
logged into your spot your spectrum i
started paying your bill by accident
instead of mine i'm like that literally
sounds like a you problem like i gave
you my login and now i owe you 500
thanks girl i'm like this is not gonna
work for me um
so yeah i almost got my
my wi-fi shut off which was just like so
crazy well i did get my tv turned off
times tough times and it was too late
for me to like wait for the next airing
so i didn't watch it which i felt bad
about um but i then i just went to sleep
i will talk about it a little bit at the
end it wasn't like a crazy eventful
episode feel free to spoil it we're like
we're in this weird plateau
space where like none of the women are
fighting but like they all like hate
each other it's just weird it wasn't a
very good episode and something needs to
happen soon because they're making
moments that aren't moments for sure but
it sounds like something happens in
aspen that we can yes yeah
so this was like a nice boring trip it
did make me want to go to mexico though
i love a boarding trip sometimes i
personally don't need drama in my life
agreed i'm a drama freak early and i
like to see friends being friends on a
boat that's just me though yes i agree i
do think sometimes like it's so
manufactured that it's like i'd rather
see these women getting along yeah but
like it's not that fun when they get
along this group
yeah especially because they do all
secretly hate each other right but like
i think in atomic
in potomac when they get along like
there's nothing better but they're never
getting along yeah so i agree with you
but this group it's not working there's
really not that tight there's also like
a huge divide in the group like the new
girls and the old girls yeah and even
the old girls i feel like are starting
to hate each other like i think kyle's
like getting over erica well i think
because
the kyle like cares about what the
audience thinks about her and like being
really close with erica and rena is not
good for her q score it's not rina is
insufferable like really insufferable
but i'll get into it in the end of the
show um we've got five pretty atrocious
stories no no i feel good about that
okay i feel good about them and we also
have the power of the brass and straws
and i meant to let everyone know like
when i did the meet and greet not only
were we singing brass and stress of
course like every other person do you
see the girls with the bryson's shirts
of
course
we should make merch 100
but also like everyone a lot of people
were talking about how they're living
for like the butters mystery i know
oliver should we give an update dog walk
dynamic we did find out who mystery
belongs to mystery is an influencer you
know mystery's mom is an influencer so
like it wasn't that hard a couple people
sent it to us and were like what are the
chances that this is mystery and we're
like oh 100 who else names their dog
mystery no and also like we've seen
mystery that's exactly what mystery
looks like so it's either the same breed
and the same name but we didn't describe
to you guys what mystery looked like so
you were like here's a dog named mystery
and it's mystery well obviously
mystery
no mystery is mysterious no longer no
longer um i haven't seen butters
actually in in a minute butters comes
through a lot with rice and the
afternoon walk yeah they're kind of like
a duo by happenstance i told you i saw
butters like literally go after bryce
one day yeah in my hallway but bryce has
learned to defend himself he's not
afraid he won't back down from a fight
bryce thinks that he's much bigger than
he is he does and he can handle butters
please please don't worry about bryce
but so the boys are doing well the boys
and girls is mystery a girl or a boy
it's a mystery no is butter is a boy
butter's definitely a boy butters is a
boy because his name on instagram is
mister don't tell it and
do please do not blow up these people's
dog's instagram account like like can we
just have this fun we have this one
thing like i don't need butter's mom to
hear that i said he was aggressive and
where's muzzle okay
mystery is a man and his mother
sometimes calls him
that's
mr
good way to remember it even though
i would have totally thought of it so
it's a group it's a pack of boys it's a
pack of boys
wow
the boys the back
the boys are back
wow that's so good to hear that theo has
like you know
a nice solid friend group like a click
he has a friend group who do you think
is the messy block of the group
rice i'm thinking butters
butters is mystery is claire
no
mystery is claire mystery is like alicia
like you're not gonna mess with her she
like
she'll mess with you like don't mess
with her she's set in her waist who's
claire
gotta reread the quickbooks i feel like
we we re-watched the movie recently i
think for toastmasters movie is
literally like oscar-worthy drama yeah
did i invite you to my bbq
then why you all up in my grill
what do you want stare
that would be so [ __ ] good are you
from moscow then why are you rushing oh
that's good i don't remember that one i
know he's from the book if you have a
daughter you know god willing are you
gonna have her read those books oh
probably not because even though they're
so good
but like we grew up in the culture yes
of like where the cool thing was like
girls the click like that was the movie
of our generation mean girls and now if
you act that way like cancelled like
literally not going to college like you
have to
that's just not how things work you're
100 right like and i actually talk about
that a lot in my new york times
bestselling novel girl with no job
available on amazon how like we were
raised in the era of like mean girls
bring it on it was like throat cut
throat mean cool table loser table nerd
band geek like now if you're at the
loser table like that's the cool table
yeah no and it's like if you want to get
anywhere in this life like you got to be
at the loser table now yeah and you
can't even call it the loser table and
it's not the loser table it's just like
not the cool table you know no it's like
what would the table be called
sexually active band geeks
yes yes um
okay so your children will not be
reading the click right no i know like
you really don't want to like set them
up for failure like because they come
from a cancelled mom you don't want that
for that we live in a different world
it's true it's true i wonder what the
click equivalent will be
when we have like teenagers
well we wouldn't know yet that's
exciting though we should get on that we
should we should write it we should
write it bryce schreich dyson dress
brazenstrasse from rosin's dress
and miss bryce always and forever in my
heart we should bring the boys tomorrow
it's friday friday bringing both boys is
hella chaotic i know but it's like if we
if no major news breaks that we need to
put on you know our diane sawyer which
we do all the time
then why not have a chaotic stress and
energy stress and energy i mean strassen
is
is best so i'm never going to say no
stress is rat the stress is right new tv
show
the price is right nah the stress is
right yeah
i feel like we've larped enough okay
that felt really good just let's get
that out larpio
sometimes you just need to get it out
100
so now without further
do here are the fast side stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
peloton oh yeah you might not feel
motivated to get up and get moving the
peloton truth peloton is here for you
they have a team of world-class
instructors that are ready to motivate
you 24 7. peloton instructors are highly
trained fitness professionals who
motivate you throughout every workout
whether you're a regular at the gym or
someone who is new or getting back into
working out whatever your fitness level
peloton instructors don't just teach
they motivate peloton has thousands of
live and on-demand classes so you can
always keep it fresh from cycling and
strength training to yoga and running
you can experiment with new types of
movements judgment free at a level and
pace that feels good for you i know that
you are a peloton ambassador an unpaid
ambassador oh now paid right i love my
peloton as you all know i do think my
bike misses me these days i do opt for
some tread classes right now but i think
the whole lap in general is like girl
get back here which i i love to come
back to peloton you know what i think
this ad is reminding me why not get on
the bike today i think i'm ready for the
bike um
rarely coming
if you want to follow me on peloton my
name is jackie o w i am really good at
class curation because i look at the
music first and i you know all the
instructors are great but some really
mesh with your personality peloton
classes are more personal than food more
personal than comedy but there is an
instructor out there for you there is
right now is the perfect time to try out
peloton the peloton bike plus is now 500
less it is the best price yet and it
includes free delivery and setup there
are more game changing prices available
on the original peloton bike and the
peloton tread visit
onepeleton.com to learn more that's
onepeleton.com
and today's episode is also brought to
you by firstleaf it feels like you
needed degree in grapes to find a great
wine you can shop by label i guess you
can try to remember what tannins are but
it should be easier and that's why first
leaf does the hard work for you they
make it simple to discover new wines
you'll love without the hit or miss
first leaf samples over 10 000 wines a
year from around the world and they
select only the finest bottles they take
the time to learn what you like what you
don't like and then they'll send you
world-class wines tailored to your taste
it's so easy to find wines you love with
first leaf
um i've never been like very into like
learning about like scents swift swirl
sip spit
nodes and fur sleep just makes me feel
like a queen who can like oh do you just
want this bottle of red like come over
to my small label that i've discovered
it's like an indie winery yeah i'm not
like other girls um and first leaf is
doing all the hard work for you because
shopping for wine is labor intensive
it's intellectually stimulating and it's
too hard um and you don't want to carry
all those wine bottles home so
try first leaf it doesn't get simpler
there if you're not happy with the wine
you receive they will credit you for
another so sign up today and you'll get
your first six bottles for 39.95
plus free shipping so that's six bottles
of wine for under forty dollars go to
try first leaf dot com slash toast
that's try t-r-y-f-i-r-s-t
l-e-a-f dot com slash toast to get your
first six bottles for
39.95 plus free shipping try first leaf
dot com toast that's truly an unbeatable
price like wine girl is no wine girlies
no okay let's get into our first story
some sad couple news we talked about on
breaking bread last night so if you were
there you already know that kendall
jenner and devon booker have broken up
after two years together the kardashian
star and phoenix sun shooting guard have
broken up after two years a source close
to kendall tells e news the source
shared this is the quote this is the
information that we're working with as
to why but you know schedules
different people right kendall but it
worked for two years maybe he's not
obsessed with health
maybe kendall and devon hit a rough
patch recently and been split for about
a week and a half the couple had a
really nice time in italy together
during courtney's wedding the insider
explains but quote once they got back
they started to feel like they weren't
aligned and realized they have very
different lifestyles kendall told devin
she wanted space and time apart
according to the source who shared they
have been in touch since and do care
about one another the insider also knows
it might not be a permanent breakup they
both hope to make it work but as of now
they are split take all of that with a
grain of salt aside from the fact that
they're broken up because if it's
if it's a kardashian-related story and
it doesn't come from tmz like
i don't know and tmz didn't break this
so let's just keep that in mind but
under the assumption that this is true i
find this really sad and i'm also
really shocked by it because i felt like
they were a great couple like in really
when people are private like you know
it's legit you know we knew nothing
about them other than the fact that they
were together and that they were private
yeah and that they were good looking and
then every once in a while we would get
a picture and was premium yeah and i
liked that i liked that for kendall yeah
and you know what's really sad
stormy of it all yeah i know that's what
everyone's saying is that what i saw um
i didn't know that stormy was so
obsessed with him until the some of the
italy pictures emerged
and oh and kendall said it on one of the
late night shows got it and then i saw
nori's black book posted that she was
thinking of storming right now because
if you don't know about allegedly stormy
is obsessed with debbie like in love
like obsessed
lights up when he comes around but these
are the unintended consequences of
dating while all your sisters have kids
you know and you bring them around the
kids and kids get very attached and i'm
sure you don't think about it but you
know this is someone who might have been
important to stormy and some of the
other kids and stormy's gonna think that
like devin abandoned her because
obviously it's not appropriate for him
to still hang out with stormy you think
yeah
uncle devin
if devin and travis were really close
which i don't know that they are then it
might be more appropriate but like no
like a 30 year old man hanging out with
a child no of course they're not going
to hang out one-on-one but he could
still come around you know the girls
keep the men in the loop they do that's
true that's like a very unique
kardashian characteristic they keep
these weenies around i just don't think
that this is a contentious breakup
because i don't think i don't know devin
whatsoever i don't think i've ever heard
him speak or anything but these two just
seem drama free you know i could see
kendall being like we're cool we're
friends like it's just
not like other girls you know she can be
friends with her ex yeah exactly she's
the type yeah like you know straight
guys and straight girls can be friends
so maybe this doesn't mean the end for
stormy no but i think it it's the end of
the relationship and now it's like we
have to add her to the list
can actually him too because he's super
eligible of course he's super eligible
and apparently he's really good at
basketball yeah very good is there
anyone on our list who might be
compatible with kendall already and for
those who are new here this is our list
of young sexy hollywood single people
who we might want to set up with each
other oh michael bjordan michael b
jordan chris evans
shawn mendes
i don't actually like i actually could
see kendall dating sean mendes just like
because i feel like they're both kind of
like weird like you know like
i can't explain it but like
you know like i don't see it remember
when that he fake dated haley bieber
for the met gal such a unique moment in
history and then she deadass got married
like six months later
yeah
that was weird that was that was like
textbook pr and he like said in an
interview he was like yeah no i was like
we like fully set it up like it was
fraudulent and they both admitted it
appreciate the honesty i do appreciate
the honesty 100 um but that was also
like a head potential that couple
but that was like it was weird because
like
to be spotted because i could add camila
cabello to our list too even though she
was spotted out with the founder of
locks club yeah which felt like a locks
club like partnership i can't explain it
oh yeah i guess it would behoove him to
be spotted as a an eligible batch and
like the headline was like
camille cabello yeah blocks club was in
the headline yeah maybe you didn't know
lux club as a dating app and now now you
know now you know
um but that guy is hot austin the
the founder of blocks club extremely
good-looking
um
back to our list back to our list back
to haley bieber oh yeah so now that i'm
thinking about it more like the fact
that they made their debut as a couple
on the met gala red carpet is so weird
because people don't really do that
no they get like spotted first you know
what
it was just like it was small time it
was small potatoes you know that's like
they're both bigger stars they would
never do it now they've moved on to
bigger and better things but sometimes
you got to do what you got to do and
maybe they wouldn't be where they are
now if it weren't for that cringy moment
that's like how god works you know
everything happens for a reason yeah god
works in mysterious cringy ways god
works in mystery
mystery dow jones mystery period
okay
are you ready for our next story i am
jesse smullett insists that he's not a
piece of [ __ ] says he gained clarity
from jail sure disgraced actor jesse
smelled professed his innocence and
insisted he's not a piece of [ __ ]
smullet who was found to have paid two
men to pretend to be racist and
homophobic homophobic donald trump
supporters and attack him with a
nuisance bleach was sprung from a
chicago jail in march after serving a
six-day sentence the 40-year-old actor
addressed his highly publicized trial on
sway calloway's serious 40. yeah that
was an interesting fact he's giving like
26 because like only like a young
immature person it's like a childish
thing to do you know yeah no
uh he was on his way in the morning
claiming he did not lie about the attack
he said if i had done this i'd be a
piece of [ __ ] and i don't think that's
really questionable smell it said in the
episode that aired on monday i actually
do think it's questionable because we're
all sitting here questioning and there
was a trial and everything right right
um here's the thing like
in general you know people make mistakes
and
they're i believe in redemption
and all that jazz you need to ignore
that if you're gonna still lie if you're
gonna stick to the same guy he can't he
he's in so deep he literally went to
jail like he cannot now claim well he
could say it now that the trial's over
and because that's the only way to move
forward from this you know a sit-down
interview where you cop to it
as long as he maintains the lie like
there's there's nothing to say yeah but
i i can't see a world in which he tells
the truth like that would be insane
because like even now like we know every
time i see him sticking to this i'm
shocked i'm shocked that i thought he
was saying he's not a piece of [ __ ] like
he didn't mean it and he's sorry no
okay but let's say
the reason why
he can't do it is because we all know
like this was a big fat lie like it was
we all know there was a trial and there
was like
half a percent where it's like
well
no
there's a little the possibility is
there but if he comes out and says he
lied like there's no possibility there's
no possibility that he's telling the
truth the jury had to be beyond the
shadow of a doubt yeah
yeah no um i can't believe it and it's
like
until proven guilty and you are proven
guilty it's so true when does that part
when does the hammer come down on that
part such a good call also i find it
like shocking that he's doing press like
let's say we got an email like dead ass
like jussi sommelier wants to come on
this show
we would obviously do it right
yeah that's
generally speaking when there's someone
who like we've talked crap about i
actually don't feel the need to
interview them but this would be
different yeah no and like do you think
like i would be like nervous i'd be like
no you definitely didn't do it like
i'm like not good at like confrontation
that's why i would never be like a
housewife right and that's also why we
can't have people on who like we're not
interested in fighting with like yeah
being confrontational we want to support
people we can't support you you
shouldn't be on the show that's true but
like i don't think we could give up like
the opportunity because we could go from
number two on the spotify charts to
number one joe who
who
the what experience
[Laughter]
the toasty experience that's what it is
um so sometimes i do sit and think like
because i'm a delusional queen like if i
had juicy smelly on the show like let's
go yes hypothetically
i know in like actuality i would be like
i'm so sorry you went through that
but like i like to think i would be like
why did you lie i'd like to think we
would like that i like i'd like to think
i'd be like you know literally nobody
believes you like do what you can go on
as many podcasts as you want but like
you're a
big liar yeah i wonder how sway handled
it yeah
good person i guess you should have
listened to the interview yeah
for boarding office
no
no
no juicy wishing you wish you were the
best but like you gotta go like the
public life is not for you like no there
are very very very few things in this
life that you cannot come back from and
this is one of them especially if you
continue to maintain the lie if you want
to you know hold yourself accountable
for say you're sorry go to therapy like
i would still think you're a [ __ ]
friend but we could begin the journey of
forgetting it humanizes you yeah
um also is a chris brown story a story
yes okay because that's a good segue of
things people can't come back from let's
get into you know me i'm not a cancel
girly like i don't believe but there are
a couple people who i believe
should
so fans are slamming normani for working
with abuser chris brown on a new song no
normani is being annihilated by fans
online for appearing in chris brown's
music video
we parentheses warm embrace the former
fifth harmony singer shared a snippet
via instagram on tuesday which showed
her dancing sensually with and even
kissing the controversial crooner the
comment section popped off quote girl
what the [ __ ] literally quote literally
that's that's the comment like what the
[ __ ] quote but i'm so confused others
are sure to quote delete the post with
some calling it quote disappointing
another quote we were all rooting for
you broken hearts
others were more specific about their
qualms writing quote why would you link
up with a man like him quote could have
worked with anyone else but someone with
multiple abuse allegations quote i can't
believe we're still working with him and
quote no not the abuser no it's true
like
what is with like people are obsessed
with cancer culture like you fart in the
wrong direction like your career is over
we have literal photo proof
of chris brown physically abusing a
woman
who's a public figure like
this chris brown thing like never stuck
and remember when he did that music
video freaky friday like kendall was in
it like that was [ __ ] loser energy on
kendall's part i think that like the way
that people will not let go of chris
brown is really suspicious and weird
yeah and also it the problematic
behavior continued past rihanna like of
course but it was just with less fate
like ryan is the biggest singer in the
world like that was you couldn't ignore
that yeah
i think this chris brown thing is so
weird i've always thought about it like
not to keep referencing my book but i
did talk about it in my book like some
cancer culture is so stupid because it's
so like not nuanced like there's unequal
punishment for equal crimes actually
yeah no it's not
the punishments often don't match the
crimes but sometimes the canceling like
cancellations sticks sometimes and
sometimes they're lifted
but it's with for people like chris
brown you know right no and it's like
that's the exact type of person who
shouldn't be
like let back in like if he wants to go
live he should live a private life but i
think he still has a record label he
releases music it is he's doing collabs
with normani what the [ __ ] is she doing
yeah she's in her flop era honestly like
i don't know what's going on i said what
i said
whoa
like normani was
literally like
there was so much hype for normani like
post
fifth harmony pre her true solely solo
debut motivation that sickening
basketball performance which was like
the cutest of all time she was like that
song with sam smith so much momentum and
like this is what you're doing is floppy
you're like a tick tock turn yes i
really like it it's very descriptive
right so like i'm not saying that this
is the truth but people could say like
you know speak now was taylor's flop ear
right you know was it
it wasn't that who that's me using it in
a sentence who in the chroma
individually refers to like a period of
time or like an album from an artist
it's just like they're doing the least
like you know what katy perry's flop era
bon appetit
you say eera or era
i don't know
what you want era era let's go get our
ears parsed
um so yeah really like this [ __ ] bothers
me so much yeah
and then don't be coming out of here
people being like all in the comments
claudia you're against cancel culture
yeah cancel culture refers to people who
say dumb [ __ ] on twitter not people who
go out here beating up women like you
finding yourself defending someone who
beats up women like you're the problem
girly look in the mirror committing
crimes committing crimes
yeah
the chris brown of it all has always
confused me
yeah
and that's and that's my opinion
and that's what you're here for to share
your opinion yeah and i just have to say
like if you don't like it
um
you're wrong so that's on you are you
ready for our next story no because
speaking of being wrong this is a
message to everyone who's never used
canva pro baby canva pro is back making
content is an essential part of what we
do to keep the show going is it has not
always been a seamless creative process
jackie nor i are graphic designers no we
don't even know barely how to use
photoshop like but we have to be
churning out content because we are
literally number two on spotify like and
you don't get there by not having
premium content and thanks since we
found camera pro we can design anything
like a pro on any device canva pro is a
design platform that empowers you to
create and share stunning content in
just a few clicks designing with canva
pro is amazingly fast and fun you can
choose from thousands of templates that
are easy to customize or start from
scratch so when we make content you know
quote cards guest cards announcing
things happening our schedules every
graphic you see on our instagram is made
on camera pro it is so easy we really
don't really know how to like make stuff
but canva has these templates you just
plug in change their name to claudia
that name to jackie boom you're done
people think you have a fancy designer
um design like a pro with canva pro and
right now you can get a free 45-day
extended trial when you use our promo
code just go to canva.me
toast to get your free 45-day extended
trial that's
c-a-n-v-a dot m-e slash toast canva dot
me slash toast
okay our next story a little biz news
and nobody wants to hear ted sarandos
the ceo of netflix explain why netflix
will add new ad supported tier to
streaming service too this is kind of
hot ads are coming to netflix yeah he's
not bad looking he gives like bob iger
energy like you know like
captain man businessman of beau even
though i think um
i think ted is a wife but whatever
never stopped me before
am i okay netflix is cozy she really
wants that special i really do like i
wouldn't
i would do it
like hypothetically like
if you had to if i had to like i would
do it for a special like i would go on a
date with ted sarando's wine and dine
him okay a date is different then yeah
no i mean i'm a married woman but like i
would give him a little this you know
like a little hate ted
i'm not like other girls
i would do it okay
one thing about me i have no scruples
that's good none
netflix's co-ceo ted sarandos is
speaking at the canline advertising
festival on thursday he confirmed that
the future of the streaming giant will
include ads explaining the about face
netflix has long been averse to
advertising on its subscription service
but after posting disappointing figures
last quarter showing it lost 200 000
subscribers the company said it would
you didn't know about that no that's
crazy
i know that they've been having a
trouble for netflix i know they've been
having trouble but i didn't know 200 000
subscribers that's so many yeah in a
quarter the company said it would be
introducing a less expensive ad
supported tier to its service in a bid
to bring in new customers he said quote
we've left a big customer segment off
the table which is people who say hey
netflix is too expensive for me and i
don't mind advertising he said on
thursday speaking on the canline stage
with sway podcast host difference way
difference wow this is like this is with
kara swisher the morning sway tech yeah
everything's called sway sway house
he was in the sway house he said quote
we're adding an ad tier we're not adding
ads to netflix as you know today we're
adding an ad tier for folks who say hey
i want a lower price and i'll watch ads
so that's like how they do it on peacock
and paramount plus and i have to say i
hate it because like me i'm always going
to go cheaper options and then i'm like
this [ __ ] sucks like why does this
one have ads no and it's like i have to
have paramount plus because that's where
drag race is and like i did the cheap
one because i'm like a cheap [ __ ] and i
was watching i'm like this is literally
like primal like this is so tacky yeah
these commercials i could vomit
so then i had to upgrade and then it's
just like now it's just it's really
starting to add up and i have to really
evaluate like what services i can live
without and which i can't live without i
can't live without hbo max they've
become incredibly important to me i
really can't live without hulu either
they've also become incredibly important
to me desperate housewives is on there
glee is on there kardashians kardashians
obviously did you finish the season
finale you know what i actually didn't i
watched it last week i didn't watch the
final episodes the [ __ ] no
the fudge is right like
i was
i was
i can't criticize them like literally
it's not coming out of my mouth like no
give us more episodes it was more it was
good i will say like there were so many
things i loved about the show
there was a couple things i didn't like
and the lack of any content like
literally 10 hours we used to do like 22
crap episodes on kardashians i was
disappointed by that i was disappointed
in the time slot
um i was disappointed in the lack of
kendall and kylie it felt like a lot of
the same disappointed in the jumping
around first it's christmas then can
kylie's giving birth in february then
we're like back in november
uh didn't like that yeah so i know it's
their first season on like a new style
and a new streaming service so i'll give
them i'll give them a pass but but they
need to
come around to realizing like
we're not stupid like
no they've been trying to pull the wool
over our eyes for a really long time
three episodes ago kim was shooting s i
swim which she shot in january on the
final episode chris is recording her
christmas song with travis like oh
even someone who's not obsessed with pop
culture would be like what is this
timeline yeah it's
and they get called out for it and they
like keep doing it and they think
they're like getting better at it but
they're actually getting worse but
what's the point
maybe to make episodes equally
interesting putting like a really
interesting thing and a boring thing
together yes but i also think astroworld
like threw them through a loop this like
they had to i think edit a lot of the
the show yeah cause like highly content
they didn't want to seem insensitive
yeah so maybe like that's partially to
blame i don't know maybe next year
here's what i don't understand about
netflix and ads
if you need to do ads on your platform
you should go ahead
but why not do like integrated ads like
it's sponsored by
spritz and like there's spritzes in it
and like yeah the advertisers will pay
you to be in product placement product
placement everybody likes product
placement i'm pretty sure they've been
doing that forever like their original
shows have tons of product placement but
i don't think it's enough to subsidize
the company i think product placement is
more powerful than an ad i'm gonna skip
through i completely agree like
traditional commercials like youtube ad
breaks like they're so old school and
they don't work anymore like i love
product policemen just like i love
spritz society use code toast expert
society.com i agree with you like as two
marketing queens um i think like
traditional commercials are like not
successful at selling products right and
like if i'm just watching selling sunset
and like christine is drinking like a
cool you know sparkling cocktail i'm
like oh i should try that right like
that's really how it works marketing and
advertising yeah so free idea ted i do
think they do a little bit of it but i
would suggest ramping that up yeah it
doesn't bother me at all it doesn't
bother me at all except you know when it
bothers me when it's like so obvious
when the house rises when bravo had two
housewives jorinda and sonia go see that
rebel wilson and anne hathaway movie and
sit down and talk about how the movie
was so great because it's two powerful
females just like them like yeah that
was really bad embarrassing when they
were like doing something with prive
that like glam squad yes and every time
they would have an event they would like
have pre-they come right that's actually
a better integration because the girls
were just the makeup artists were
wearing t-shirts and it didn't bother me
but the movie was it was a low point
really bad that's how you knew we were
headed for a recession
that was a low point in pop culture
history yeah are you ready for another
low point for our fifth and final story
sure
i don't know if there's you can sing a
song about this no i know i'm not
singing
jewel e-cigarettes will be banned in the
u.s after a two-year review
jewel e-cigarettes will soon be off the
shelves at least according to a report
that states the fdi is planning to ban
the product from being sold in the u.s
the wall street journal reports the fda
is gearing up to order joule to remove
its products from the market following a
two-year investigation the report states
jewell had asked to keep the company's
nicotine products in rotation jewel
first came under fire nearly four years
ago for marketing to young users with
with its sleek design and flavors
ultimately leading to a spike in vaping
and underage people
the company has been hit with thousands
of lawsuits in the us and tried to turn
things around by banning the fruit
flavored products but clearly that's not
enough for the fda which is reportedly
taking things to the next level also
it's worth noting that other
e-cigarette brands are still on the
market right with the fda
separating the two because those other
products help people quit smoking
whereas jewel is very like teen focused
but it's really they're the same thing
it's just about how they've been
marketing the fda is giving such karen
vibes here like we're literally
suffering a nationwide nationwide baby
formula shortage and you're like
obsessed with e-cigarettes like [ __ ] off
like there's so many there's so many
things in this country that are so bad
for us like literally video games with
kids getting their heads blown off like
it's so stupid like uh fentanyl like why
don't you focus on that not [ __ ] easy
literally people are dying of accidental
fentanyl overdoses all the time like
work on that [ __ ] like not [ __ ]
e-cigarettes that like just kids like to
smoke in clubs like all right the kids
might have a cough but they'll be fine
okay maybe they have coverage no
but also like they've made they banned
the fruit flavors you know that which
made a huge idea to buy them i think is
probably at least 21 like all of these
things that they can do like but yeah
okay then make it 21. yeah just like in
new york you have to be 21 to buy
cigarettes
no
no you do in this state i believe that
you do i'm like almost 100 sure that's
not true it's google it yeah let me
google it but you can keep talking um go
off says
just
get some baby formula on the shelves
lower the price of gas deal with
inflation yeah no oh you're right it's
21.
i remember from my days but can i just
tell you like yes
jewel was
forced to stop selling all their flavors
like years ago uh they literally still
sell it in every vape shop there's like
counterfeit ones being made they're
being sold in from other countries like
and that's nobody gives a [ __ ] and
that's worth it i really don't know how
this jewel ban is how many people are
actually going to stop vaping because of
this ban instead they'll just get you
know [ __ ] up pods that actually might
harm them in a more serious way that is
such a good call like i just i don't
really understand why they're like all
up in everyone's business it's not like
anyone's being forced to jewel it's a
personal choice we live in a free
country and i just think the fda the
food and drug administration can be
really focused on some of the issues
going on in our country that people
actually care about like if we lived in
a perfect world like then you could
focus on you know if we had no other
problems like maybe we should tackle you
know smoking but like get some baby
formula on the goddamn shelves and then
worry about jewel no but you know what
like even with the jewel i don't really
agree with that like it's a choice that
too it's a choice like we live in a free
country and if i want to choose to vape
and ruin my lungs like that's my choice
and food and drugs some freaks who work
in the government like shouldn't be able
to tell me what to do with my body and
it's weird that some brands can stay and
jewel has to go and it feels they've had
this hard-on for jewel for years it's
very like
you know back door deals yeah and jewel
is not the popular company in the class
yeah
i just think like this is
like unnecessary and yes maybe it's
because i enjoy vaping and maybe that's
just on me but i also just think it's
like nobody's business what you choose
to do to your lungs and i wish like the
resources being put towards this moronic
cause would be put towards worthy causes
and that's on being rational 100 and i
don't even vape anymore and i think this
is moronic and an overreaching
government regulation 100
and you know government girls it kind of
makes me want to choose no totally like
oh i can't jewel bet you're on [ __ ] now
when you say i can't do something now
i'm going to prove that i can do it
right because this is america yeah [ __ ]
yeah
i really could use a jewel right now
i think i might have an extra one in my
purse somewhere fda you've convinced me
yeah thanks fda look at your influence
no interest
i had no interest before but you get one
for harry you just reminded me of how
jewels are no you should get one for
harry the fda
the fda
gave you that idea thanks fda
um i want to talk a little bit about the
real housewives of beverly hills yeah i
would like for you to share your
thoughts and it's brought to you by
babel for all we are babble you guys we
love babble for all of your summer
travels whether you're going abroad or
staying domestic and you want to immerse
yourself in the culture now is the
perfect time to start babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions thanks to babble's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons there's still time to
learn a new language before you reach
your destination so me and better
supposed to go to italy and the last
time i went to italy i did not do babble
and that's how i ended up with the bonui
situation so i've started um doing
little podcast little games on babel
it's really fun it's really easy and i
just think if you're gonna be traveling
abroad this summer like it's just not
the smartest or safest thing to go to a
country where you know none of the
language
you can get lost you can get
pickpocketed like it's just you want to
know what you're doing when you travel
so with babel you only need 10 minutes
to complete a lesson you can start
having real conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
other language learning apps use ai for
their lesson plans but babel lessons
were created by over 150 language
experts their teaching method has been
significantly proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages like spanish french
italian and german right now save up to
sixty percent off your sub subscription
when you go to babble.com
tmt that's babble spelled b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com slash t-m-t as in the morning
toast and that's for up to 60 off your
subscription battle language for life
you know who loves babble
who the campers because they can all
communicate american campers and
learning french and italians
because she wants to connect with the
international campers and she wants to
stop having beef with them did you know
that american camper is 12 now wow
how do you figure that out she was eight
when she started okay okay and it's been
four and eight years old wow yeah yeah a
medical marvelous eight when she first
went to camp when she hopped on the
scene yeah oh my god i saw a tick tock
today of like these girls at like a camp
it was like a classic camp you know like
north
new england and they're wearing like
their sophie shorts and they're doing
like a little tick-tock dance outside
the bunk and like it first of all made
me so nostalgic for camp and then it
also made me realize like how grateful i
am i didn't go to camp in the tick tock
age like we really got to like look ugly
and like not give a [ __ ] why are they on
their phones these kids i don't know if
for us like we had cell phones maybe
like a little bit older but you were
banned from bringing them to camp and
you could live without cell phones back
in the day i don't know if kids
are going to camp without their phones
now what i remember is like kids bring
their phones and they get them at call
time that's like what's going on
that was like 10 years ago that's what
happened to us like 10 years ago
that was a long time ago i mean there
shouldn't be phones at camp no it's so
nice like
camp is so much fun you don't need your
phone it's so toxic you're out there
getting fresh air stimulating your mind
kids mental health these days they're so
toxic because of their phones if i if i
which i will send my kids to camp like i
want to find a camp that's a no phone
camp yeah it'll be they'll hate me for
it in the beginning but they will be so
grateful yeah when they're when they're
home yeah
it'll be good for them it will be okay
beverly hills so most of the trip uh
most of the episode took place on the
boat trip they got this like nice boat
and diana i [ __ ] hate diana what yes
first of all she's like i mean this
isn't like a yacht it's like a nice day
boat like she was just being obnoxious
and she like hates sutton and i hate her
because of that it's just it's like the
same with crystal last season it's like
sutton you think is the weakest link and
it's just not interesting to have strife
with her no and she's just she's she's
not the girl i thought she was like yes
her life is really interesting but she's
so condescending like about her money
and it's it's like kind of annoying that
is annoying um
and this is like might be like a really
[ __ ] up thing to say but like i don't
think you should ever be condescending
about money but like if you
built your own business and like
went from nothing to something all right
i can understand how you feel like you
could be condescending but like she
married her money so let's just let's be
real yes but the ex-husband did say that
he couldn't get to where he was without
diana sure
um but he said it no for sure and you
said that he knew he did say it but like
i think he's just a nice guy like was
diana working at barclays bank no you
never know okay um but so what was
really interesting about the boat ride
was that erica showed up on the boat
ride like blackout like literally
blackout she was slurring sleeping on
the couch talking to herself she is
sonia morgan
she was laying on the couch we used to
have a boat
we bought docked it in marina it was
called the illegal which is weird um and
she was just like going on and on about
like old timey boat and she was giving
sonia morgan yeah yeah yeah she looked
incredible i kind of wish he wasn't that
drunk it was like maybe the best look
i've ever seen her really her glam was
so like natural and stunning her hair
was pulled back at a low pony she was
wearing this really cute i think it was
missoni cover-up and she just looked
like fresh and young her body looked
amazing because she literally fell
asleep on the couch with her legs wide
open her legs were like tan and smooth
and gorgeous and i was just like i wish
we could have enjoyed this look because
she looked amazing like she was just it
was like a low-key look she's always
doing the most yeah she was like this
understated glam that i thought she
looked really beautiful oh i can't wait
to see this um but she and all the women
like thought it was funny but then they
were talking afterwards how she said
she's on antidepressants and garcelle
was pointing out how like she's been
like probably mixing alcohol with like
the wrong pills and it's just like not a
good cocktail and it wouldn't have been
such a big deal because they're like on
vacation and whatever but like
she's just going through a lot and she
said she's on pills and like now now
you're it's not like funny it's like are
we worried about erica right and we've
known erica for a while now and that's
not really
lisa rana said for the seven years i've
known her i've never seen her even close
to this strong so to be that drunk when
you know she's at a low point is
worrisome yeah um because some people
like get really drunk all the time like
by accident or you know what i mean some
people have like low tolerances or
whatnot but eric has always been like a
drinker but she's not been like a sloppy
mess and that's what she was with her
legs spread like
screaming obscenities like obscenities
um so the boat ride was like just really
revolved around erica
what's her name diana got stung by a
jellyfish i enjoyed that
um crystal oh and then there was like
this weird moment like on the boat
and then at dinner where like erika and
sutton are like vibing hard like talking
about how they're both southern and like
their moms never showed them any love
and then eric went on this weird drunken
rant about how like agriculture was life
and if you didn't work you didn't eat
and it was just like okay
um but then towards the end they went
out to dinner on their last night and
they're just like vibing and everyone's
like talking about it um and they don't
want people to be like talking about it
and pointing it out they just want to
like chat so i don't know what that
means because
uh
sutton was like the last time we vibed
on that boat in
wherever they went last season you're in
your confessional saying you hate me but
you're just like talking to me to make
the trip nice like i don't know if
you're actually doing that now or if you
actually want to move forward but for
the most part there really wasn't any
confrontation for erica and son to move
forward me too because by the way like
they were talking about how um
sutton met this guy on bumble and was
showing a picture of him to erica like
it was really cute because they're both
like newly single i think that there's
something there um if they can get past
it if erica can like stop being her
villainous self which she was not being
this week which i appreciated garcelle
also brought up denise because the
garcelle's birthday party is next week's
episode and she said i am bringing
denise and lisa rena said she has to be
in new york for harry hamlin's movie
premiere um but then lisa arena was like
you know i i did reach out to denise and
apologized for how i acted and she said
that she appreciated the text and then
garcelle and her confessionals texted
denise and was like did lisa arena text
you and denise responded when
so i don't know if lisa was lying or
denise just doesn't remember but that
was interesting um and then the episode
ended in like a weird like moment where
they were trying to make more drama
between diana and sutton so they get
back on the plane you know it's diana's
plane
and
they're sitting at the four top you know
two seats in two seats and it's like
kyle
uh diana and crystal and sutton's like
oh can i sit here there's one more seat
left next to diana and jenna's like no
go to your original seat like sit the
way you sat on the way here she was like
okay then everyone sits down like
they're all in different seats than they
were on the way here and sutton's like
so upset she's like i could have gotten
my own plane it was like so dumb and
gross i was like yes you could have like
trying to empower her like it was so
dumb um but diana like is [ __ ] rude
like i i don't like diana like i'm over
her completely
damn okay i'm gonna catch up i'll
probably feel the same as you because
that's usually how things go around here
um but thank you for the recap i feel
like it's a pleasure it's a pleasure it
wasn't like anything life-changing oh
but you know what is life-changing our
interview with craig conover which is
yes
we haven't mentioned that the whole time
so we had craig caught over in studio
yesterday he filmed a podcast with us so
if you're listening to this as a podcast
just keep easy listening keep listening
to our gorgeous don't go anywhere if
you're watching on youtube it's only
available as a podcast so check it out
on spotify or itunes or wherever you get
your podcast he talked about the new
season of southern charm he talked about
naomi and paige he talked so much about
paige and just like
how he's she's made him a better man it
was so cute he looked great he was so
cute and he's so nice like he really is
the nicest guy it was a pleasure and
southern charm premieres tonight you
guys that's exciting we'll be watching
yeah what else is on tonight no it's
just wednesday had everything
yeah i like because i haven't watched
the real housewives of dubai and i know
that the three first episodes of
ultimate girls trip in the berkshires
just came out this week
or today and i just like can't really
stress how little i i want to watch
either of them
yeah i will probably watch ultimate
girls [ __ ] but i just feel like i know
what it's about already it's vicki
versus rinda and it's just like messy
versus messy and it's like vikki
verstander that's yeah vicky's like why
are we in this old smelly house and
dorinda's like so offended by that
because that's what the whole season
about is about like her offending her
stately historic home oh god but i
understand like the other women got to
go to villa turks and caicos and we're
at someone's house well you're also like
the b team right i do there are people i
do want to see like do you want to see
jill and i really do want to see taylor
armstrong yeah but i also feel like this
ultimate girls trip is kind of an
audition i wouldn't be surprised if some
people do come back from their shows if
this goes well for them yes yes yes yes
so
we'll see could be starting lineup after
this so southern charm tomorrow and
that's not on that oh and you know what
i watched
hacks
the whole season what did you think it
was so good it was just as good as
season one like long enough not no but
it was perfect the arc of the story was
great it left like it was just as good
usually the second season is a flawless
flop era but i loved the story line and
i'm sure like you felt very warm and
fuzzy towards it because of the special
too yes it was first of all i think they
really nailed what it's like to sell a
special because it's [ __ ] hard even
if you're famous i thought they nailed
like tour life like literally going to
lord and taylor and drinking fountain
soda like it was so good my only
complaint is that there wasn't enough
debra vance like we're getting to know
so much about ava and her chief of staff
and the water guy who cares yeah
literally who cares i like that
housekeeper though i want more of her
she's um
what is she from
she's from something so iconic from our
childhood
yeah hold on i think she's from the
sweet life of zack and cody we're not
going to let you go until we find out
hacks cast and then of course the little
brother from ugly buddy oh of course of
course and from oh he's from sweet life
of zach and cody i've got beef between
my teeth it would be lost
without my floss iconic what is the
housekeeper from
she's in that's so raven oh yeah she's a
teacher thank you okay
great she's the teacher great i feel so
much better i love when that happens
she's also a bad teacher
wow are you gonna be okay
no no
no i'm curious how they will do this
into the next season because like they
should be separated hopefully it means
no more ava that would be
sensational oh and i loved like the
moment when she decided to like go back
spoiler alert go back to her roots and
sell her special on qvc like that was so
iconic yeah and then of course like she
proved the concept and everyone came
running with like millions of dollars
but i just love that like her fans have
always been there for her i just i loved
it it was giving toast energy honestly
it really was like giving patreon it was
giving patreon like you know what like
who cares what the bigwigs think like
your fans are always here for you you
built a community they love you i felt
like i honestly felt so connected to the
show more than i did even last season no
in this storyline also i like the fact
that like the jokes
in the beginning like they were fine the
crowd wasn't really with her and you
could sense that because i was like
that's kind of a shitty joke yes it's
not that funny and then like the jokes
about by the end like they're
really great like yeah
so good so good i loved it um and i
can't wait for the next season and i
can't wait for tomorrow because it's
friday oh yeah and it might be strategy
it might be friday you never know with
these boys one could get a tummy ache
and should not come to work it's true
never know sensitive stomachs yeah all
right so if you're sitting in a podcast
here is our interview with craig conover
if you're watching on youtube head over
to the podcast app or spotify and enjoy
our little moment with craig conover we
love you guys and we'll see you tomorrow
bye
you